what we discovered is that when you  offered higher wages you got a much  better applicant pool and what do I mean  by that well you got people that were  not only smarter but were more  conscientious and more motivated to work  in the public sector and so not only did  you attract this better pool of  applicants but you also got them to  accept the job more often so they're  more willing to actually sign on the  dotted line so the most obvious lesson  is that financial incentives do matter  for attracting these people into public  sector work there are people out there  who believe that you shouldn't offer  higher wages to attract people for for  either NGO work or public sector work  because they feel that you might be  crowding out those people who are who  are motivated for the cause and are  willing to do it for less money and what  we show is that that isn't the case and  in fact you don't necessarily have this  trade-off